[Music]
foreign
ER makes a rare public appearance with
her look-alike daughter my daughter's so
sweet Jen brought her daughter Violet as
her plus one to a White House State
dinner on Thursday and the event which
was held in honor of French president
Emmanuel macron marked Violet's first
state dinner event and served as her
birthday celebration too you have to
for your kids Violet who turned 17 on
Thursday looked gorge in a black
Carolina Herrera gown covered with black
shining hearts a tiny matching purse and
red stilettos she held hands with her
famous mom who rocked a long
form-fitting sleeveless black Ralph
Lauren dress with matching heels why not
but Jennifer who shares Violet with her
ex-husband Ben Affleck wasn't the only
celeb at the State Dinner who brought
their kiddo along Julia Louis-Dreyfus
took her 25 year old son Charlie Hall
who looked Dapper in a tux I am so
grateful to be here as for Violet we've
only caught rare glimpses of the Teen
over the years like at Jen's 2018 Walk
of Fame ceremony my family Violet Sarah
and Sam
hi buddy
but one thing we do know Violet is smart
and strong just like her mama
but my daughter said mom there's a
stoplight in the water and there's a
stoplight and through that stoplight
it's a lock to the ocean
yeah proving they can handle pretty much
anything Jen told that terrifying yet
hilarious story back in 2018 about the
time she got lost kayaking in Sweden
with her then 12 year old daughter
I called them and said um we're next to
this and this and they said yeah no turn
around
suddenly it was like we saw this blonde
human with the sun behind him like a
Halo and he was coming to a rescue and
he showed up and he led us back and his
name was Matthias oh my goodness
we'll never forget Mathias never forget
from kayaks in Sweden to the Walk of
Fame to the White House one thing's
clear Violet is Jen's best sidekick
[Music]
thank you